Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier! And welcome to Those Nights at Rachel's.
Now this is made by the same guy that made... The Joy of Creation.
So you know it's probably going to be good.
And this was also made in the Unreal engine, so I don't know if it's going to be fully-
(Phone call) "Hello, and welcome to your new job-"
Hiii!
"at Doug's and Rachel's."
Hi, you sound excited.
"We have the best animatronics, and food available at the lowest prices."
Oh jeez.
"Straight up guaranteed."
Ah-hah?!
"Since this is your first night at the job, we'll connect you to a live call with our colleague."
Hokay...
"They'll be your guide for the first night."
"Have fun! Bye."
Hokay th... thank you!
Who am I calling? Live call... Oh god, damnit!
Hi... Why is the...
(Live Call) "Uh, Hello... Hello? Hello?"
Hi!
"Are you there?"
Yea?
"Uh- hi! Uh, you must be the new night guard."
"Well... uh if that's the case, which it probably is,"
"then I'm supposed to help you with our 'amazing' technology."
OOOoooooh...
"It's a bit... It's a bit cheesy, but you get the point, right?"
No, no, no I eeeoorgh...
"Well, for starters, the company thinks that"
"putting up security cameras in practically any corner is going to help,"
"and honestly I don't think it will, with what you're gonna have to deal with..."
-boops-
"Uh, but anyway, you can-"
-boops again-
"switch the security feed-"
*booping intensifies*
"using the click of our standardized mouse that the company put out.
Okaay...
"Heh, that's one way to describe it."
Oh jeez...
"It's reeeeally old, but... uh we'll get through it!"
Ah-huh?
I'm... I-
"But uh, let me tell ya. The power bill gets expensive-"
Jesus!
"With almost every damn night guard."
What am I looking at?
"So, hopefully by limiting the power, you won't be like them."
By... like who?
"Unless, you can track the power on the secondary monitor, and for God's sake-"
*groaning*
"Do nooot break it!"
I do-
"Honestly, I feel like I'm repeating myself at this point."
Ugh!
"Power is usually measured through the closeable doors in your office,"
"which can be closed at any time using the Z and X keys."
"And you'll need to shut them as soon as something-"
*Mark sighs*
"uh- undesirable may appear."
"Uh, you probably don't know what I mean, which in that case, it's probably-"
What was that?
"-for the better."
Okaay!
"But, anyway, don't leave them shut."
Hukay!
"Uh, alright! A few more things,"
"and then I can set you on your way!"
Alright!
"You actually have a spare room next to your office."
Great!
"Which has pretty much been deserted for some time."
Coool!
"However, we used to allow employees to go in there, but uh... ah... mmmm..."
"Kinda had an accident in there."
"Uh... needless to say, don't ever let those curtains-"
"-open all the way."
Eugh!
Why na-hah-at?
"And if you by chance actually see anything, or anyone back there-"
*spooky laugh*
Aargh?!
"Uh, don't go telling-"
Who the fuck...
"the media. Oookay?"
Aw, shit!
"We've had some rough edges in the past-"
Aw shit!
"And probably even more than I've seen myself."
AAH! Shit!
"But...uh-"
Ah shit ah shit!
"Long story short-"
Aaaah...
"always close the curtains."
Fffaaahhhck!
"Don't ever ask why either, it's just company rule."
Shit, that wasn't the right door!
"Honestly, I-"
"heh, I don't even know myself."
"You can walk there using the W key.
"Oh! Um, if an animatronic,"
"specifically a raccoon and uh..."
Aw what the f, what the fuuuck?
"the thing, from the curtains,"
The TING?!
"find their way into your office-"
Oh god, it's two doors!
Euw...
"You can't hide from them."
"Somehow, they have increased awareness, possibly some sort of uh- developing mistake?"
What?
"Uhhhh, i-it's best not to think about it too much."
"So, uh... yeah! That'll set you on your way-"
YEAH!
"Close the cur-"
"Oh! Oh oh wait wait wait, one more thing."
Aaah!
"If two of our 'amazing' animatronics somehow manage to... uh..."
"find their way to BOTH of your doors,"
What the FUUUCK?!
"we found a small trick for that."
"Hiding under the desk seems to actually help, and even saved my lif- I mean ah, uh, my job."
Weugh...
"Well, it, uh, helped me save my job one time."
"So, uh, yeah. Close the curtains, monitor the building,
Oh God!
"Grab the flashlight, hide under the desk,-"
Uhuh!
"And you'll be promoted as soon as you know it!"
"But actually... please don't hurt yourself."
"We've had some.. issues with our reputation, and it went downhill recently."
"Damn pizzeria down the street. Fazbear's Pizza, or somethin'."
"Somehow it's managed to absolutely DESTROY our reputation"
"due to them having some sort of... robot incident."
"Uh, after that discovery, animatronics may just be looked at in a different... way."
"Tch... yea."
"Uh, It's a bit unsanitary and rude, but customers are customers."
Ahuh?
"We need them, we need their cash."
Oh... What?
*phone clicks*
(Monotonous phone voice) "Hello and welcome to your new job at Doug's and Rachel's."
WHAT?
"We have the best animatronics and food available at the lowest prices. Straight up guaranteed."
Wai... er...
"Since this is your first night at the job-"
Wait weyy wooow woooow
WHAT THA FUCK WAS ALL O' THAAT?
What he FUCK just happened?!
Wai... a... did I miss some here?
(Previous phone caller)"Shit- fuck! God dammit!..."
What the fuck?
"Uh- hello?."
HII!
"Uh, Hi! Uh welcome back to Doug and Rachel's, and uh... yea..."
"Um, company didn't really want me to record any phone calls after your first night-"
Okaaay... why?
"But I figured, why not?"
"After all, they don't monitor the calls after the first one, so I'm safe to say what I want! Heh..."
Ah-hah?
"Well, for starters, which I'm sure you know by now,"
"the animatronics are REALLY jumpy."
"Uh, easiest way to say it is something like... performing after hours,"
"but with a bit more of a kick."
"They seem to actually move around the building, and no one knows why..."
"Actually... uh, one of the night guards tried to do some 'investigating' himself,"
"uh, which probably was the dumbest idea ever."
Yea! Somethin' like that.
"Poor kid. It's safe to say that it didn't end particularly well. Hah."
HahHAAAHAH!
"Other than that, nothing really happened recently,"
"although I really shouldn't say that yet..."
Whow! What the fuck is that?
"You're our fourth... er.. fourth- fifth... FIFTH night guard right now,"
"um... the others being in an unnatural state...
"Hahmm... one of them even stopped talking,"
"and they all have some sort of verbal communication problem... Very strange! Huh!"
"They had to take him to some therapist, and the family tried suing us!"
"Cool! Uh, despite all their efforts, of course it didn't work."
Ah hah!
"Nothing ever does, all it takes is the company's little money before they just wash all the troubles away."
Okay!
"Uh, shouldn't question it, and neither should you for the sake of our job at least."
"As hellish as all this may seem, you'll get through it. Almost all of us do."
Just stop being so subtle about things, yehh... swanky bastard!
I dunno why these are still closin-
That was like a million HOURS of conversation that I didn't need to talk about-
Aah- There's so much information
that they just threw at me, how am I supposed to be able to comprehend all o' it?!
It was all wrapped up in an enigma with bullshit about how I'm gonna DIE!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
This is a load of bullsh- HI!
Who the fuck are you with your green-glowing Outlast-bullshit eyeballs?
*Creepy, deep laugh*
Oh... Aeugh ffuck you!
Whoooooooo the fuck is that?
Whoa shit, that doesn't sound good.
Get the FUCK OUTTA HERE!
And the crontroools!
I don't know the controls yet, why did you put away the controls?
*Frustrated scream*
Hokay...
I just needed to get that panic outta my system
so that I was able to actually comprehend what FUCK was going on here!
It's already 3 a.m., everything seems to be bullshit and horrible!
What the fuck!
I... this threw me into the deep end into the pool
faster than I've ever been thrown in my goddamn life.
You wouldn't like... holy shit. Oh my gawd.
Okay. So now that I'm done panicking,
let's actually try to do something about this and close these goddamn curtains,
whatever the hell is gonna be poppin' outta the goddamn curtains!
How am I supposed to be able to know ANYTHING?
God, I can't even keep track of what's coming down the hallways!
Like I don't know... I'm missing one.
One is definitely missing...
One's over there, but there's another one that's mi-
Eugh. I dunno what's poppin' outta there!
I had to listen to the phone call for about ten fuckin' minutes!
Which is fine! I get- I get backstory needs to be put out there,
but I don't remember, like they were tellin' me hints on how to hide
and when to go back and the only thing I remember is 'go back to the goddamn curtains'
so that I close 'em for SOME FUCKING REASON!
And then go about my goddamn life, which I don't understand fully!
Augh man...
And I get the most snarky boss that ever existed in the world of... Fuckin' animatronic bullshit here.
But I haven't even SEEN a goddamn animatronic!
They're puttin' it out like I'm gonna die in two goddamn seconds, but nothing has attacked me!
What the fuck- What was that?
Hello...
But I don't know, one-once it get's further in the nights,
how am I supposed to be able to get all the way to the back here
and be able to close this bullshit,
and then go all up all the way to the front?
Uuh shit, what was that?
Sorry.
I'm in a just a bit of a tizzy.
So I'm hopin' that everything's gonna be okay.
I got power to waste, so I'm pretty sure...
Yea, it's almost six a.m. so...
Well...
Alrighty then...
Hokay...
*Heavy sigh*
Anyway.
G'bye...
Sooo...
Just like that!
I don't know if there was something bugged about the first night
or just because the phone call went on so long, but it seemed like-
it seemed like it cut him off when there was vital information, and I'm already on the third night!
What the hell?!
That doesn't make any sense, there was like no threat yet.
What the hell happened?
I am so confused. I'm so confused. Oh boy!
"Don't you think taking the endoskeletons was enough?! wuuwait- oh shit!"
*dial tone*
What??
"Uh, hello?"
"Uh, sorry about that. Just... accidentally picked up at the wrong moment."
"Other than that, uh... welcome back to Rachel's, of course."
"By now, I'm sure you have the hang on things, so there's actually no point of rambling on. Heh."
'"I'm actually just surprised you've uh, lasted this long."
"I mean- with your job... uh, yeah!"
Wait!
"Uh..."
Piggie's gone!
"Uh, anyways,"
"I've heard some news lately-"
Ah-hah?
"Nothing really interesting of course, you know..."
"Except the fact that the owner is missing... weirdly..."
"No one has seen him anywhere in the building. A bit strange, don't you think?"
"Uh, not that I really care, just curiosity. Hmm, y'know."
"You uh, you wanna know the worst part?"
"We won't get promotions without him being here!"
"I uh- hopefully, wish he comes back..."
"For the sake of a promotion at least..."
"It's stupid to think of getting the promotion by now though, interestingly enough."
"Probably due to the fact that the owner doesn't really want to be attached to the company"
"or the mascots for some reason."
"Maybe he hates this place for whatever reason, maybe as much as we do? Haha."
OH GOD, THEY'RE ALL GONE!
"I know I do!"
"In many ways that you'd probably not ever imagine."
"Uh, this place sure does have a shady past..."
"God, aaaaalright. So I think I'm gonna call it quits now.
"I'll chat with you tomorrow. See ya."
*dial tone*
Yea, if I'm gonna BE here tomorrow!
They're all off the stage and I can't even find 'em on the frickin' camera!
Like s- Oh hey, how's it going! That is nearby to me, isn't it?
Uuoh shit!
What- that's another door? I don't even know what that door is!
It's like off to the left! How do I do that? WHAT DO I DO!?
I don't know what the fuck I do!
I don't understand any of this bullshit!
Eough!
Just gotta close whatever the hell this curtain is!
*Gasp* What was that?
Uuh shit.
Oh shit.
Hi!
Hii!
HI!
OH HI!
Bull-ass piece o' crap!
Bull and big friends?
Eugh boy!
They're going to hang out with the dog in the house-
Or is that a cat? I have no idea...
Oh man...
Fuck me.
God, what is with the curtains?
What is with any of this in this game?
Aw man...
Oh boy...
I'm gonna close at least one of these doors, just because...
it seems like I got more than enough power to be able to last through the day.
Ooh... What are they doing? They're goin' to the raccoon's hut?
Why?
I did not know there was a raccoon in there, but I'll...
take your word for it and this guy is getting awfully close to me...
Ka... Yeah, there's three doo-
Oooh! The-That's the backroom on the right there, ok. So he's comin' up the...
Okay, so I-I'm gonna close the other door...
'Cause...
Yeah, he's not comin' down that way...
I should probably check on the back area.
Okay, that was pretty wide open.
I need to be more mindful of that!
God jeez...
Ah jeez, ok, he's moved...
Where did he move to?
Are you all pow-wowy...
*Loud, distorted scream*
OOOOHOOOW FUUUCK MEEEE!
I don't understand!
I don't get it!
What the hell just happened!?
Hwhat?
I don't know!
What the fuck!
I don't.. I have no idea... Oh man...
Hokay.
I'm gonna end this episode here, because-
This is bizarre. They threw so much information so quickly, I have no idea what to do.
This is.. This... A aand what's weird is it seemed like nothing was happening
It was very hard to get a wrap on, there was so many different things to do
that it was impossible to get a grasp on anything
and yet nothing was attacking me for two nights straight!
What the fuck, I don't get it, wow.
Something... I need to wrap my head around this so I'm gonna end this here.
Let me know what you think in the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you. In the next video!
BUHBYE!
*outro*